Sergey Brin : J'aimerais parler d'un sujet.
Je sais que cela en a fait réfléchir plus d'un.
Nous vous avions parlé il y a quelques années.
Et avant que je ne commence,
comme beaucoup se posent encore la question,
je souhaitais en finir.
La réponse est "boxers".
Maintenant, j'espère que vous vous sentez mieux.
Est-ce que vous savez ce que cela pourrait être ? Est-ce que quelqu'un sait ce que c'est?
Dans le public: Oui.
Qu'est ce que c'est?
Dans le public : Ce sont les personnes qui se connectent sur Google à travers la planète.
Ouah, OK. Je n'avais pas vraiment compris la première fois que je l'ai vu.
Mais c'est ce qui m'a aidé à le voir.
Voici ce que nous utilisons au bureau, c'est du temps réel.
Ici il y a peu de connexions.
Mais vous pouvez voir à travers le monde
comment les gens utilisent Google.
Chacun de ces points qui s'élèvent
représentent environ 20 à 30 recherches,
quelque chose comme ça.
Ils sont triés par couleur, par langage.
Vous pouvez voir : ici nous sommes aux États-Unis,
et ils deviennent tout rouges.
Ici nous sommes à Monterey. J'espère que c'est cela.
Vous pouvez voir que le Japon est occupé la nuit,
juste ici.
Nous avons Tokyo qui vient en japonais.
Il y a beaucoup d'activité en Chine.
Beaucoup en Inde.
Il y en a au Moyen-Orient, les petites poches.
L'Europe, où il est midi,
a une forte activité avec une grande diversité de langues.
Maintenant vous pouvez également voir, si je tourne cela
espérons que je ne secoue pas trop la Terre.
Vous pouvez également voir des endroits avec peu d'activité.
L'Australie parce qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de monde.
Enfin, et c'est quelque chose sur lequel nous devons travailler
l'Afrique avec quelques fils,
surtout en Afrique du Sud et quelques grandes villes.
Fondamentalement, nous avons remarqué que ces requêtes,
qui arrivent par milliers chaque seconde,
existent là où il y a de l'électricité.
Et partout où il y a de l'électricité, il y a Internet.
Même en Antarctique -- du moins à cette période de l'année --
nous voyons de temps à autre une requête monter.
Si nous avons bâti cela correctement, je pense que
la Station Spatiale Internationale en a également.
Voici
un de nos défis :
il est assez difficile de ...
Allons-y.
Voici comment nous devons déplacer les bits pour que
les personnes aient les réponses à leurs questions.
Vous pouvez voir pas mal de données circuler.
Elles traversent le monde : à travers les fibres,
les satellites, par tous types de connexions.
C'est assez compliqué de maintenir les temps de réponse
aussi faibles que possible. Heureusement, le ressenti est bon.
Mais nous pouvons revoir que des endroits sont beaucoup plus connectés
que d'autres, ici la bande passante aux États-Unis,
ça part en Asie, en Europe dans l'autre direction etc.
A présent, j'aimerais vous montrer à quoi
ressemble une seconde d'activité.
Si nous pouvons passer aux diapos --
parfait, c'est parti.
Voici la version ralentie.
Une seconde ressemble à cela.
C'est ce qui nous occupe le plus
à savoir,
faire en sorte de gérer tout ce trafic.
Chacune de ces requêtes
a une vie personnelle intéressante.
Cela peut concerner la santé de quelqu'un,
sa carrière, quelque chose d'important pour eux.
Ou cela peut traiter de choses aussi
importantes que la sauce tomate,
ou dans ce cas, le ketchup.
Donc cette requête,
c'est un groupe connu, mais plus connu dans certains pays que dans d'autres.
Vous pouvez voir que cela a commencé ici.
Aux États-Unis et en Espagne, c'était à la mode au même moment.
Mais nous n'avons pas eu le même pic aux États-Unis
qu'en Espagne.
Puis de l'Espagne, c'est parti en Italie,
puis l'Allemagne s'y est intéressée et puis le Royaume-Uni.
Il me semble que, finalement, les États-Unis ont
commencé à aimer aussi.
Je vais vous faire écouter la chanson.
Passons, vous l'apprécierez à sa juste valeur --
espérons que cette requête va marcher.
Un de nos buts
pour développer notre société
est d'avoir plus de recherches.
Cela veut dire que nous souhaitons
plus de personnes en bonne santé et éduqués.
Plus d'animaux, s'ils commencent à faire des recherches à leur tour.
Pour résumer, nous souhaitons faire de ce monde un meilleur endroit,
la Fondation Google fait partie de ces projets,
et nous sommes en train de la mettre en place.
Nous avons déjà un programme appelé "Google Subventions",
qui finance plus de 150 organisations caritatives dans le monde,
en voici quelques-unes.
Je suis très enthousiaste d'en faire partie.
En fait, beaucoup d'organisations qui sont ici
le fonds Acumen, ApproTEC, je ne suis pas sûr que celle-là soit active --
nombre de ceux qui ont présenté à TED fonctionnent grâce à "Google Subventions".
Ils affichent des publicités Google et nous leur permettons de faire la pub
pour qu'ils puissent se faire connaitre.
Un des premiers résultats a été
avec un homme d'affaires de Singapour qui sponsorise un village
de 25 jeunes vietnamiennes pour leurs études,
c'était un des premiers résultats. Il y a
eu beaucoup, beaucoup d'histoires comme cela depuis.
Nous avons une centaine d'associations partenaires
et la fondation Google sera une tentative encore plus ambitieuse.
A présent, est-ce que quelqu'un sait qui c'est?
Ha! ha!
Dans le public : Orkut
Oui! Quelqu'un a trouvé.
C'est Orkut. Est-ce que certains d'entre vous sont sur Orkut?
Y en a-t-il?
Ok, peu connaissent le sujet.
Je l'expliquerai dans un instant.
Il est un de nos ingénieurs.
Nous avons découvert qu'ils travaillaient mieux couverts de feuilles.
C'est notre secret pour lancer de nouveaux produits.
Orkut avait l'envie de créer un réseau social.
Je sais ce que vous pensez tous : "Encore un réseau social."
Mais c'était son rêve, et en gros, nous pensons
qu'il faut laisser les gens faire ce qu'ils souhaitent réellement faire.
Donc voici ce qu'il a construit.
Nous l'avons lancé en phase de test le mois dernier
et c'est en train de décoller.
Voici notre Vice Président en charge de l'ingénierie.
Vous pouvez voir ses cheveux rouges, je ne sais pas si vous voyez son piercing au nez.
Voici tous ses amis.
Donc nous avons décidé
que les gens s'enverraient des invitations pour utiliser le service
c'est le personnel de la société qui a commencé à faire passer le mot.
Aujourd'hui nous avons grandi jusqu'à plus de 100 000 membres
Cela se propage très rapidement, même en dehors des États-Unis.
Vous voyez que même si les États-Unis représentent la majorité
c'est seulement 30% de notre trafic.
Cela touche déjà le Japon, le Royaume-Uni et l'Europe
et le reste du monde.
C'est donc un petit projet assez fun.
Avec une variété de tranches démographiques. Je ne vous ennuierai pas avec ça.
C'est le genre de choses que nous essayons pour le fun
et regardons ce que cela donne.
Et...
bien, je vais laisser le suspense.
Larry, je te laisse expliquer celui-là.
Larry Page : Merci Sergey.
Donc Sergey et moi-même
sommes allés dans une école Montessori
et je pense que cela
a été incorporé au sein de Google.
Sergey l'a mentionné avec notre ingénieur Orkut
qui a réalisé Orkut pendant son temps de travail.
Nous avons appelé cela à Google "les 20%".
L'idée, c'est que pendant 20% de votre temps,
vous pouvez travaillez sur la chose qui vous tient à cœur.
Beaucoup, beaucoup de produits Google viennent de là.
comme Orkut ou Google Actualités.
Je pense aussi que pleins de choses dans ce monde viennent de cela.
Mendel, qui enseignait aux lycéens,
a, vous le savez, découvert les lois de la génétique
sur son temps personnel, comme un hobby.
Énormément de choses utiles en ont découlé.
Et Google Actualités, que j'ai cité,
a été lancé par un chercheur,
qui, après le 11 septembre, s'est beaucoup intéressé à l'information.
Il s'est dit : "Pourquoi ne pas m'informer mieux?"
Il a donc commencé par regrouper cela par catégorie
puis à commencé à l'utiliser, puis ses amis.
Pour permettre l'envol de cet outil,
nous en avons fait une Googlette,
qui est un petit projet chez Google.
Cela rassemble en gros 3 personnes
qui essayent de créer un produit.
Nous ne pouvons pas être sûr de sa réussite.
Dans le cas de Google Actualités, quelques personnes
ont travaillé dessus pendant un certain temps, puis de plus en plus
de personnes l'ont utilisé, nous l'avons donc lancé sur Internet,
et de plus en plus de personnes l'ont adopté.
C'est aujourd'hui un projet à part entière avec une équipe plus étoffée.
C'est comme cela que nous continuons à innover.
D'habitude, plus les entreprises grossissent,
plus elles ont du mal à développer des projets innovants.
Nous avons eu ce problème aussi pendant un temps,
puis on s'est dit : "Il nous faut un nouveau concept."
et nous avons créé les fameuses Googlettes -- un petit projet dont le résultat est incertain.
Nous espérons que cela va marcher, et si nous en avons assez,
certains vont réellement décoller comme pour Google Actualités.
Puis nous avons eu un problème car nous en avions plus de 100.
Je ne sais pas pour vous,
mais moi, j'ai du mal à gérer 100 choses dans ma tête à la fois.
Nous avons donc trouvé qu'en les mettant tous sur écrit
et en les ordonnant -- les choses se sont arrangées d'elles-mêmes.
Ne faites pas attention à eux.
Par exemple, "Acheter l'Islande" inspiré d'un article.
Nous n'allons jamais faire une chose aussi insensée. Mais...
simplement, en les écrivant et en les ordonnant,
d'ailleurs l'ordre de tri n'a pas été un grand sujet de débat.
Ce qui m'a plutôt surpris mais
nous avons trouvé qu'en gardant 100 choses dans la tête,
en les couchant sur le papier
cela permettait de décider facilement quoi faire
et où allouer nos ressources.
C'est donc ce que nous avons réalisé et institué
il y a quelques années, ce qui nous a permis de rester innovants
et assez bien organisés.
L'autre chose que nous avons découverte est que les gens aiment travailler sur des sujets importants
et naturellement,
auront tendance à se diriger vers les grandes priorités.
Je voudrais mettre l'accent sur certaines choses
nouvelles, que vous pouvez ne pas connaître.
La plus importante étant la DeskBar.
Combien d'entre vous utilisent la barre d'outils Google?
Levez la main.
Combien utilisent la Deskbar?
Très bien. Vous devriez l'essayer.
Si vous allez sur notre site et tapez
Deskbar, vous la trouverez.
L'idée est d'avoir une application en permanence
en bas de l'écran
qui permette de faire les recherches facilement.
C'est une amélioration de la barre d'outils.
Merci Sergey.
Un autre exemple de projet qu'une personne
passionnée de Google a lancé
et c'est un vraiment un super produit qui décolle.
Google Réponses que nous avons démarré
vous permet moyennant 5 à 100 dollars
de taper une question
et de disposer d'un groupe de chercheurs
qui va enquêter pour votre compte, le service est garanti
et vous aurez au final de très bonnes réponses
sans y passer du temps.
Froogle vous permet d'avoir de l'information sur des produits
et Blogger vous aide à publier des choses.
Ce sont tous des projets innovants que nous avons testés.
Nous essayons beaucoup, beaucoup de choses
dans notre société.
Nous aimons aussi innover dans notre espace physique,
dans nos réunions, vous savez, vous devez attendre longtemps
pour que les projecteurs s'allument et s'éteignent.
Ils sont bruyants, donc nous les éteignons.
Nous n'aimons pas cela donc en
quelques semaines, nous avons conçu ces petites coques
qui enferment les projecteurs donc ils sont tout le temps allumés
et complètement silencieux.
Résultat, nous avons ensuite conçu des logiciels
nous permettant de gérer une réunion.
Par exemple, quand vous entrez dans une salle
cela liste toutes les réunions en cours,
vous pouvez prendre des notes facilement et les envoyer automatiquement
à toutes les personnes qui étaient présentes.
Comme notre compagnie se mondialise,
ces concepts nous aident vraiment.
Par exemple, comment travailler efficacement avec des personnes non présentes?
Ce genre de choses. Des questions aussi simples peuvent faire la différence.
Nous avons beaucoup d'ingénieurs dans ces réunions,
qui ne font pas leur lessive assez souvent.
Nous avons donc trouvé utile de mettre à disposition
des lave-linges, surtout pour les jeunes employés.
Nous acceptons également les chiens et autres animaux domestiques.
Nous possédons, je pense, une culture très fun à Google
qui aide les personnes à travailler et aimer ce qu'elles font.
Voici notre image "Culte".
Je vais la montrer rapidement.
Nous avions cela sur notre site pendant un temps,
et avons vu que depuis
nous ne recevions plus de candidatures à nos offres d'emploi.
Passons, chaque année nous emmenons
toute la société faire du ski.
Beaucoup d'avancées se font dans les sociétés où les gens se connaissent, et aussi de manière informelle.
Nous avons fait du bon boulot de ce côté là.
Cela fait de Google un endroit où il fait bon travailler.
Nous le voyons avec nos logos aussi qui intègrent
notre culture de changer les choses.
Au début, on nous conseillait de ne jamais
changer notre logo car nous
devions établir notre marque,
et donc pour cela ne jamais le changer.
Il fallait qu'il dure.
Puis on s'est dit : "Ce n'est pas très fun.
Pourquoi ne pas le changer chaque jour?"
Une des choses pour laquelle j'étais le plus enthousiaste
est un projet appelé "AdSense".
C'était peut-être un présage
c'était avant que Dean n'abandonne.
Mais l'idée est que, comme dans un journal,
vous lisiez des publicités pertinentes.
C'est dur à lire, il est écrit : "Bataille pour le New Hampshire:
Howard Dean président" -- articles sur Howard Dean.
Ces pubs sont générées automatiquement
comme ici, sur le Washington Post
à partir du contenu du site.
Nous utilisons donc plus de 150 000 régies
et des millions de publicités, nous avons donc choisi
les plus liées à ce que vous regardez,
comme nous l'avons fait pour le moteur de recherche.
L'idée est : "Pouvons-nous rendre la publicité utile,
au lieu d'agaçante?"
Le point positif,
c'est que nous avons un programme en self-service
auquel beaucoup de sites Web ont souscrit
pour réellement gagner de l'argent.
J'ai rencontré une personne une fois, dans une soirée,
un gars qui gérait un site classé et
qui m'a dit : "Tu sais, je ne gagnais pas d'argent.
J'ai juste intégré votre solution et je gagne maintenant 10 000 $ par mois.
Merci.
Je n'ai plus à travailler maintenant."
Je pense que c'est très important pour nous car cela fait mieux fonctionner Internet.
Le contenu devient meilleur et donc la recherche plus facile
quand les individus peuvent vivre
en créant du bon contenu.
Cette session est supposée traiter du futur,
et je vais au moins en parler brièvement maintenant.
L'idée derrière cela est que faire la recherche la plus précise
possible implique de l'intelligence.
Vous tapez n'importe quoi sur Google
et espérez une réponse, n'est-ce pas?
Mais trouver des choses est délicat, donc vous souhaitez de l'intelligence.
Pour résumer, le moteur de recherche parfait devra être intelligent.
Ce sera de l'intelligence artificielle.
C'est ce à quoi nous travaillons.
Nous avons des personnes assez enthousiastes
et assez folles pour travailler dessus,
et c'est leur vrai but.
Nous espérons toujours que Google soit intelligent,
mais sommes toujours surpris quand les autres le pensent aussi.
J'aimerais citer un exemple marrant,
celui d'un blog en Irak.
Ce n'est pas trop le sujet
mais je voulais vous montrer cet exemple.
Sergey, peux-tu pointer dessus?
Nous avons donc décidé --
hum en fait, la partie juste là. Merci.
Les "Recherches associées" ici. On ne voit pas très bien.
Nous avons décidé d'ajouter une option
dans nos publicités AdSense appelée "Recherches associées".
Le principe est de dire "Recherchez-vous des informations sur ...?"
dans ce cas, "Saddam Hussein" car ce blog parle de l'Irak
en plus des publicités,
nous avons pensé que c'était une bonne idée.
Dans ce blog
d'un jeune un peu déprimé qui disait
"Vous savez, je dors beaucoup."
En gros, il racontait sa vie quotidienne.
Nos algorithmes, pas une personne bien sûr
mais nos algorithmes, nos ordinateurs
ont lu le blog et ont décidé que
la recherche associée serait "Je m'ennuie."
L'auteur a lu cela et a pensé qu'une personne avait décidé
qu'il était ennuyeux.
C'était très malheureux,
et il a écrit : "Mais que font ces idiots de Google?
Pourquoi n'aiment-ils pas mon blog?"
Donc nous avons lu son blog qui devenait
de pire en pire
et la recherche associée est devenue "Attardés".
Le blogueur s'énervait encore plus dans ses textes
il commençait à jurer, etc.
Donc nous lui avons attribué "Tu crains".
Puis finalement "Baise mon cul".
Cet individu pensait qu'il avait affaire à quelque chose d'intelligent,
mais bien sûr
nous avions juste écrit ce programme et testé.
Cela n'a pas marché du tout.
Nous n'avons donc plus cette option.
Maintenant je vais revenir à la mappemonde.
Je souhaiterais terminer en disant qu'il y a
plusieurs choses qui me motivent et me poussent
à m'impliquer dans Google.
Notamment le fait que nous gagnions de l'argent
principalement par la publicité, et un des bénéfices que je n'avais pas prévus
est que nous pouvons servir le monde entier
sans avoir peur des pays pauvres.
Nous n'avons donc pas peur que nos produits soient vendus
moins chers dans des pays pauvres
et ensuite réimportés aux États-Unis
comme pour l'industrie pharmaceutique.
Je pense que nous sommes très chanceux d'avoir ce modèle économique,
car chacun dans le monde entier peut avoir accès à notre recherche,
c'est un bénéfice vraiment considérable.
L'autre point que je voulais mentionner
est que nous avons la lourde responsabilité
de fournir aux personnes la bonne information.
Nous nous voyons comme un journal ou un magazine
fournissant une information très objective.
C'est pourquoi nous n'acceptons aucun paiement pour afficher nos résultats.
Nous acceptons des paiements pour la publicité,
et nous la vendons en tant que telle.
Contrairement à beaucoup de concurrents.
Je pense que les décisions de ce type
ont un effet énorme sur le monde,
et cela me rend réellement fier de faire partie de Google.
Merci.